au fil des ans la serriculture est passé
d' activités traditionnelles à véritable
industrie aujourd'hui 70% du sirop
d'érable produit sur la planète provient
du québec pour assurer la longévité et
la bonne productivité des érables ils
font les entailles et de façon optimale
ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas mais
une formule mathématique que désormais
guider les acériculteurs avec les
résultats surprenants
[Musique]
fabriquer du sucre avec un produit qui
vient d'une forêt un seul compte qu'ils
demandent pour la déforestation
pour moi c'est magique
il
stéphane guillet et biologiste c'est un
passionné d'agriculture depuis une
vingtaine d'années il s'intéresse à
l'entaillage des érables à sucre
[Musique]
un geste qui peut paraître banal mais
qui a d'énormes conséquences sur la
productivité des érables les gens ont
appris qu'ils perdent du rendement parce
qu'ils percent dans du bois mort le bois
mort c'est l'enjeu lanta y crée des
blessures qui reste invisible en surface
mais qui affecte de façon importante le
rendement de l'arbre le trône en tête
c'est comme un iceberg
on voit presque pas ce qui se passe à
surface de l'eau c'est pareil sur
l'arbre on voit pas ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de l'arbre sous les corses
l'arbre est en mode combat il doit
contrer l'attaqué subie dès qu'on fait
une entaille la pluie il met en branle
et mécanisée défense qui vont faire en
sorte qu'ils vont fabriquer des produits
qui vont être des fongicides entre
autres des phénols ces fonds jc de façon
aussi poison pour le bois donc il va
sacrifier une partie du bois pour
s'assurer que lab sera pas complètement
contaminés plus on perd ce l'arbre pluie
secret de longues sections de bois mort
on dispose alors de moins de boissin
pour entailler on voit que cette
blessure l'a quand même à l'heure en
haut et en bas une grande importance
quand les deux sont proches et ont
tendance à la fusion puis tout ça c'est
du bois qui pue apte à la production
série comme le fait d'en taille et de
façon aléatoire entraîne donc des
conséquences économiques importants si
je venais antoyé dans la blessure d'une
autre année j'aurai pas 100% production
je pourrais avoir un 30 et 40 % de perte
de productions sur l'entente qui est
dans du bois mort c'est un enjeu de
taille quand on sait qu'en 2019
les acériculteurs du québec on perd
c'est plus de 46 millions dans taille
pour une production totale de 159
millions de livres de sirop d'érable
une valeur qui dépasse les 450 millions
de dollars
alors peut-on faire mieux il ya vingt
ans stéphane guy a eu une idée pour le
moins avant gardiste c'est cela que
quand tu travailles à un peu en
recherche fondamentale qui passe souvent
pour un farfelu
on se fait souvent dire ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait n'est pas applicable sur le
terrain moi je peux modélisateurs donc
une idée ça commence toujours par un
modèle mathématique pour moi fallait que
mathématiquement pour moi là ça soit
faisable
le scientifique a donc sorti sa
calculatrice et son gros bon sens son
nouveau modèle dans taillage s'applique
aux érables de 20 cm et plus avec un
seul chalumeau placée à 5 cm de
profondeur pour que ça fonctionne
il se base sur une croissance de l'arbre
de 1,2 mm par année la moyenne au québec
à partir de là il débute l'entaillage à
l'année 1 et perce un premier trou
l'année 2 il place le chalumeau 16
pouces plus bas pour éviter de percer
dans la blessure provoquée par la
première entaille la troisième année il
en taille encore 16 pouces plus bas une
fois qu'on a fait trois années comme ça
on se déplace de 5 cm puis on recommence
à espoo 16 pouces qui ont fait le tour
comme ça donc un arbre quinson pour elle
a travaillé pendant combien d'années
en fait on va pouvoir lataniers tout le
temps parce que quand on voit revenir
ici bas à voir ça dépend de nouveaux
bois
[Musique]
on va les voir après 20 heures
premièrement comment vous faites ça pis
si ça a marché
ici chez andré blais et son fils simon
la saison des sucres est presque
terminée l'imposant question les blais
avait entendu stéphane guay parler de
son modèle mathématique dans une
conférence
il avait une bonne nouvelle à lui
apprendre moi je t'ai vu il ya vingt ans
et 10g antoyé comme tu me dis dans la
vie de quelqu'un un laboratoire de 20
ans s'était même pas imaginable pour
moins qu'un jour je verrai ça ok mais en
plus de ça c'est que monsieur ya
quarante mélantois et là c'est pas un
laboratoire de 200 enfants et là il ya
40 mais l'entente et du vide ça se fait
que tu me disais je continue ou jettent
vous la vie que c'est fait il clique
revue parce que papa
non mais on s'est aperçu que ce sera
facile de suivre cette méthode lors
c'est à s'identifier
oui je te donne la dreale au bout de
deux heures capable comme il n'y avait
aucun mode d'emploi la famille blé a
fait preuve d'ingéniosité pour adapter
le concept très théorique de stéphanie
mathieu bélie ce qui est fait c'est que
ea yamin pinky nuit et dès qu'ils rendu
dans quel rangée avec la personne juste
besoin de trouver sous l entaille de
l'année d'avant ou deux ans c'est facile
de repérer les enfants et cinq années à
en arrière mais après ça ça commence à
être difficile parce que les corps
commencent à se déplacer puis on a plus
de difficultés mais donc faire 1,2 trop
un simple belle et à neige leur sert
aussi d'outil de mesure pour accélérer
le processus de mise en vente à mesure
de la mesure avec un y trouve ça nous
permet d'avoir tout de suite ou à les
percer et en même temps qu'un la neige
on enlève l'année sur larmes pour voir
nos anciens et aux patrons prix je peux
pas aller par cédant 1
dans une vielle aure atone qui a déjà
été soudé qui va souder ensemble fait
photo passé dans du bois saint blin et
nombreux bons
selon eux les avantages sont indéniables
tant en termes d'efficacité que de
productivité c'est simple alors que le
rendement moyen par entaille au québec
est de 3.4 livres de sirop celui de
leurs érablière et de 4,5 livre donc
pour vous ça veut dire quoi dire
feuillet cargo raktres haut représentant
10 et 12 dolan et le concept peut aussi
s'appliquer à une érablière qui a déjà
été entaillé quelqu'un qui a déjà eu une
et rabia que toutes les entorses on a
distribué un peu partout mais faut quand
même qui commence un jour fonds qui
commence pour arriver un jour à avoir
que du bois vivant et derrière ce modèle
mathématique
l'objectif toujours présent et de passer
au suivant
si mes enfants ça les intéresse plutôt
éventuellement ben ils vont à moins de
musée rath auriez fait plus pour
plusieurs générations
l'avenir de saut mais je pense que tous
les gens qui sont soucieux de
transmettre le potentiel acéricole futur
mais ils vont le faire parce que j'ai
pas trouvé d'autres façons d'y arriver
[Musique]